TUCKER WILL BE BACK.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
CHAOS IN NEW YORK CRIMINALS NOW
ARE ROAMING THE STREETS.
WE HAVE DISTURBING NEW VIDEO
THAT SHOWS A VIOLENT FELON
BRUTALLY ASSAULTING -- WE SHOWED
YOU EARLIER IN THE WEEK A RANDOM
ATTACK ON A SUBWAY PLATFORM NEAR
THE AIRPORT, THE ATTACKER
PREVIOUSLY BEAT HIS OWN
GRANDMOTHER TO DEATH, WAS OUT ON
PAROLE FOR A VARIETY OF OTHER
CRIMES.
THAT WOMAN, THE VICTIM I CAN'T
BELIEVE AFTER THAT BEATING SHE
WAS ABLE TO GET UP.
SHE MAY PERMANENTLY LOSE VISION
IN HER RIGHT THIGH.
SHE WILL JOIN US TO TELL US
ABOUT THIS HARROWING MOMENT
STRAIGHT AHEAD TO.
ALSO LATER, BUCKLE UP.
ESPN HOST OUR BUDDY
STEPHEN A. SMITH WILL JOIN US,
WE'LL GET HIS TAKE ON THE
GRUESOME INJURY FROM LAST NIGHT,
THURSDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL GAME.
WILL NEXT GET TO THAT BUT WE
BEGIN TONIGHT IN THE WASHINGTON
SWAMP, NOW LED BY SOME OF THE
DUMBEST MOST INCOMPETENT PEOPLE
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH, OUR
ECONOMY IS IN SHAMBLES BECAUSE
OF RECKLESS SPENDING.
GAS PRICES ARE GOING UP AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THEIR WAR ON ENERGY.
AVERAGE PRICE PER GALLON $6.26,
STATEWIDE IN CALIFORNIA $6.18.
OREGON $5.29.
WASHINGTON STATE $5.17 AND IT'S
ONLY GOING HIGHER.
OUR KIDS HAVE FALLEN BEHIND IN
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THEIR
UNSCIENTIFIC COVERT
RESTRICTIONS, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, OPIOID, SENTINEL
DEATHS ARE AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH
BECAUSE OF THEIR RECKLESS OPEN
BORDER POLICY.
OF COURSE IN AFGHANISTAN, AND I
WE HAVE VLADIMIR PUTIN
THREATENING TO USE TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PRETTY MUCH
DECLARING ONE-THIRD OF UKRAINE
IS HIS.
IN THE WAKE OF HURRICANE IAN
FLORIDA'S GULF COAST IS LUCKY TO
HAVE STRONG STATE AND LOCAL
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS NOT MENTALLY CAPABLE OF
COORDINATING ANYTHING, TAKE A
LOOK.
SPEAK OF THE FEMA ADMINISTRATOR
WHO'S BECOME THE MVP THESE DAYS
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH FEMA
AND THE ENTIRE WORK FORCE OF
PEOPLE DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
HURRICANE IAN.
I'M GOING TO USE THIS.
IT MADE LANDFALL YESTERDAY, WE
ARE HERE TO TALK ABOUT AMERICA.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK HE
KNOWS THE NAME OF HIS OWN FEMA
DIRECTOR AND IT GETS WORSE
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
THIS WAS MAY BE THE LOWEST OF
ALL LOWS WHEN HE ATTEMPTED TO
INTRODUCE A CONGRESSMAN HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE HONORING WHO
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY IN AN
ACCIDENT IN AUGUST AND INSTEAD
OF HONORING THAT LEGACY, HE
ASKED HER WHERE SHE IS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
HERE, INCLUDING BIPARTISAN
ELECTED OFFICIALS,
SENATOR BRAUN, SENATOR BOOKER,
REPRESENTATIVE JACKIE -- ARE YOU
HERE?
TO HELP MAKE THIS A REALITY.
>> Sean: I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE AND BROKER
AND WHERE IS JACKIE?
THIS GUY IS NOT MENTALLY
COMPETENT FOR ANY JOB MUCH LESS
THE HARDEST JOB IN THE WORLD,
BEING PRESIDENT PERIODS
VICE PRESIDENT, SHE IS NOT MUCH
BETTER.
DURING HER TRIP TO ASIA SHE MADE
A COMPLETE FOOL OUT OF HERSELF
AND FRANKLY DID NOT MAKE OUR
COUNTRY LOOK PARTICULARLY GOOD,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S SO CLOSE.
>> IT'S 50 METERS AWAY.
>> OF THE UNITED STATES SHARES A
VERY IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP
WHICH IS AN ALLIANCE WITH THE
REPUBLIC OF NORTH KOREA.
IT IS AN ALLIANCE THAT IS STRONG
AND ENDURING AND TODAY THERE
WERE SEVERAL DEMONSTRATIONS OF
THAT POINT.
>> Sean: A VERY IMPORTANT
GREAT ALLIANCE WITH NORTH KOREA?
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S SO CLOSE --
50 METERS.
GREAT JOB AS USUAL.
THE NEXT IN LINE TO BE YOUR
PRESIDENT WOULD BE 82-YEAR-OLD
NANCY PELOSI AND SHE CONSTANTLY
FINDS A WAY TO OUTPERFORM THE
STOCK MARKET WHILE HER JOB
PERFORMANCE AS A SPEAKER IS
ALWAYS LACKING.
HERE IS HER TAKE ON WHAT SHE'S
CALLING HURRICANE IRAN, TAKE A
LOOK.
SPEAK ALMOST $19 BILLION, SOME
OF THAT NEEDED RIGHT AWAY FOR
IAN.
BUT MORE WILL BE NEEDED.
>> Sean: HURRICANE IRAN.
IN THE SAME SPEECH SHE TOUTED
THE MERITS OF IMMIGRANTS STAYING
IN SOUTHERN STATES BECAUSE SHE
NEEDS THEM, SHE WANTS THEM TO
PICK OUR FRUIT AND VEGETABLES,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU SEE IN FLORIDA SOME OF
THE FARMERS AND GROWERS SAYING
WHY ARE YOU SHIPPING THESE
IMMIGRANTS UP NORTH?
WE NEED THEM TO PICK THE CROPS
DOWN HERE.
>> Sean: WHY SEND THEM TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, WHY SEND THEM
TO D.C. OR NEW YORK OR HER STATE
TO THE SANCTUARY STATE OF
CALIFORNIA?
WHAT A TRULY STUPID THING TO SAY
AND INSULTING FRANKLY TO ALL THE
LEGAL IMMIGRANT WORKING PEOPLE
WHO COME INTO THIS COUNTRY, OBEY
ALL LAWS, RESPECT OUR BORDERS
AND SOVEREIGNTY AND WORK IN A
VARIETY OF PROFESSIONS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AFTER DECADES IN POLITICS, THEY
HAVE ALL LOST TOUCH WITH
REALITY.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THEIR AWFUL
POLICIES.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY EMPATHY FOR
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ARE TOTALLY INSULATED FROM
ANY AND ALL SOCIOECONOMIC
HARDSHIP AND THEY LACK ALL THE
MORAL COURAGE TO EVER ADMIT
FAILURE AND REVERSE COURSE.
JOE BIDEN'S BIGGEST CONCERN AT
THE MOMENT IS ITALY IS SOON
GOING TO HAVE A CONSERVATIVE
PRIME MINISTER THAT HE BELIEVES
YOU OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO CALL
YOURSELF IN ITALIAN, CHRISTIAN,
A MOTHER, AND A WOMAN.
AT A CLOSED-DOOR FUND-RAISER,
JOE BIDEN SAID SHE IS THE "THE
REASON I'M SO CONCERNED THAT
DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE.
THE PEOPLE OF ITALY VOTED HER
IN.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS MOANING AND
GROANING ABOUT A NEW EUROPEAN
LEADER WHO ISN'T A WOKE EUROPEAN
SOCIALIST AMERICANS HERE AT HOME
HAVE BIGGER FISH TO FRY.
IN JUST TWO YEARS THIS INAPT
ADMINISTRATI